he's an American skateboarder actor
producer entrepreneur and reality TV
star he's one of the biggest supporters
of professional skateboarding and one of
the sports most well-known characters he
was labeled one of the most influential
skateboarders of all time by Fox weakly
he's rob dyrdek and here his top 10
rules for success I think when it when
it comes to understanding tackling fear
and relentless problem-solving right
it's a reality of learning tricks you
have to try it over and over and over
and over and keep adjusting every little
aspect of your body to ultimately get it
to work and then when you get it to work
it's like this incredible like oh my god
I can't believe I learned this and that
progression drives you even further you
know
I've always been like X like have an
idea and executed to a fault right would
say but the what I had to learn over the
last few years is you can't do it by
yourself
right like I really would have said you
know years ago I don't do it by myself I
got all these great partners you know
but the reality of it is is is I would
have my hands and so much and not you
know delegate properly and put in the
right verticals on on how and what you
want to accomplish and go out and
accomplish it I just willed everything
into existence you know and and more
than anything it's about what do you
love to do the most and what do you best
at and then do that all the time and
then put everybody else into filling the
rest you know that's sort of what I've
really been focusing on these last
couple years because make no mistake
even every person that I want to move
forward with all I care about is your
greatest quality is that you want to get
better tomorrow than you were today
but it was sort of that that big step
for me to have money to start exploring
different entrepreneurial darts if you
will had a skate job that lasted about
three months that was kind of where I
first discovered uh you know stay out of
retail started a hip-hop label you know
how to had a rap label for a little
while you know that's when I really
discovered the importance of making sure
you have a partner that's equally as
motivated and driven as you not lazy and
more than that you know just stick in
your lane and I mean like just because
you think it's cool that you're a pro
skateboarder and you got a hip-hop label
you don't know what you're doing you got
no business in that you know so and that
sort of time period I had kind of
refocused on arm just all things skate
there's this layer of transparency right
it's like the Contra preneur is that I
love the most is like there's not
there's not a bill be honest about
everything and they'll tell you exactly
how it is good or bad and we'll just put
a stake in the ground on an opinion but
not drive it home and it's it's like
that's the stuff I respect the most
the greatest energy that you can live in
is that sort of excitement of something
coming around the corner whether it's a
you know a new job or a new moment or
something big happening like there's
that energy and I've figured out how to
live in that a lot right and I think
that becomes incredibly motivating and
then when you see the results of making
yourself better how much better you get
and how it affects the world around you
like it just gives you that much more
motivation like ah man if I just get
better and better like it just
everything gets bigger and stronger and
better so it's like that motivation and
drive comes from that desire to grow and
create where I ultimately see myself I
just haven't quite got there
for the most part I don't take meetings
before 11:00 it's right I sort of build
my whole schedule around my morning and
the working out side of it just so it's
not compromised you know the only the
only way it really becomes compromised
if you begin to schedule into into your
time you know so for me it's it's really
important that I really don't take a
meeting with that student TV doing
always so we're doing whatever you know
going skating or whatever it is it never
happens before 11:00 down
I have had so many failures at so many
levels and and I think even I only
really started to get it and grow up a
year and a half ago when I finally
brought on a CEO for my company right
where he really began to to help me
learn to continue to grow and then start
put surrounding yourself with with
mentors and really smart people that
have done what you're trying to do or
what you may want to do so you can learn
from them and that really revolutionized
sort of my entire process because before
I was making millions losing millions
making millions behind they're doing
this you know I wrote produce finance
films lose a couple million like like I
was just I was so driven that it didn't
matter to me I just wanted to get things
done you know
you
you
you never want to do is put unrealistic
expectations on somebody that you're
trying to do business with because it
will straight a friendship and you got
to be smart to keep people in their you
know in their Lane and have them excel
to what they're best at you know you
don't want to have you don't want to
have you know someone in your your
particular crew take over the accounting
if they're bad with numbers and I mean
the same way you don't want to do design
if they suck it design just because you
need someone else to work on the live
stuff you know I I think you know in in
all aspects of life it's always much
farrowing you surround yourself with
people that you enjoy being around
you have to focus on always learning you
know it's even your your it's cliche but
the reality of it is is if you take
action and try and fail you're going to
learn a lot by the time you you try it
again and you will build a foundation of
experience that's going to be ultimately
the rock that allows you to find success
or follow your dreams
I don't know I've always thought global
but I've always thought big right and I
think the difference is now I have it so
clear on what I want to do for the next
10 years that I've slowed down because I
know I'm building this great machine and
it's going to take me a couple years to
get it perfectly in order before I
finally turn it off because when I turn
it on then it will it will be bigger
than anything I've ever done or ever
will do and will ultimately represent my
legacy and I realized that's cryptic but
that's how that's how far out I'm
already prepared for what I'm doing next
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because [ __ ] gay galagos asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Rob
Dyrdek's top 10 rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments I'll join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching
deep to believe and I'll see you soon